we have a remarkable update on a story
we've been following here about a man
who spent more than 40 years behind bars
for a crime he didn't commit
kevin strickland was finally released
from prison yesterday after a judge
overturned his conviction in may the
jackson county missouri prosecutor
declared strickland innocent aaron
moriarty has followed this case so
closely
erin this has got to be good news to you
well it is but it comes really late let
me put things in perspective kevin
strickland was 19 when he was arrested
jimmy carter was president
gas was 63 cents a gallon that means a
lot right now
he's now 62 and uses a wheelchair
it was warm and sunny when 62-year-old
kevin strickland emerged from a missouri
prison a free man the first time in more
than four decades i just couldn't
believe what i was hearing
yesterday missouri judge james welch set
aside his conviction and ordered his
immediate release
it took him no time to see that there
was no evidence
that said i had anything to do with this
crime before during or after strickland
has been incarcerated since 1978 when he
was arrested and convicted of a triple
homicide in kansas city in april of that
year there was no physical evidence
tying him to the murders but the only
survivor cynthia douglas identified him
strickland remained in prison even after
one of the actual shooters vincent bell
testified under oath that strickland
wasn't there and douglas realizing she
had sent the wrong man to prison
recanted at a hearing earlier this month
douglas's sister testified the toll it
took on her douglas died in 2015.
i just like to tell her thank for that
you know trying to get that done
no hard feelings judge welsh wrote
absent douglas's positive unequivocal
identification of strickland there would
have been no charge no trial and
certainly no conviction thankful for
god walking me through this for 43 years
protecting me
she let me get a little scuffed up along
the way
i guess those were learning lessons
learning lumps although strickland has
been officially exonerated current law
does not provide any compensation for
all he's lost i spoke with strickland
last month letting me out the door still
doesn't make the 43 go away
my whole life is a memory of prison
i should add that all for the real
shooters have been identified and none
are currently serving time for the
murders the attorney general issued a
statement yesterday saying the court has
spoken and he will take no further
action in strickland's case i mean i'm
happy for him but i really want to make
a point of just what he lost two-thirds
of his life behind bars for something he
didn't do and we hear this over and over
again
it just seems as though innocence
on these appeals
doesn't make a difference it really
doesn't in missouri it really
innocence isn't what matters it's
whether the judge made a mistake at your
trial and if you can't prove that you
can stay in and also if you're not on
death row you're not entitled to a
lawyer so kevin had to file all of these
appeals on his own pro se and of course
they didn't pay a lot of attention to
him
go ahead now i know compensation for the
wrongfully convicted varies state to
state but why doesn't he get any
compensation well in missouri only if
you've been freed from uh from prison
because of dna if you've been exonerated
because of dna do you get money um he is
not even entitled to social security and
if he had been guilty and let out on
parole he would have had a parole
officer to help him find a job he gets
nothing coming out so what happens to
kevin strickland now he's out in a world
that he doesn't recognize 40 years after
he went in in a wheelchair
in a wheelchair well what's important is
the midwest innocence project is
starting to go fund me um i think there
is going to be an effort to try to raise
some money for him he's going to go live
with his uh younger brother
um i you know he does
he does need to find a life he has he
has a seven-year-old daughter well i'm
sorry three forty-three
when he went in she's old she's 43 now
wow how he has handled this the man of
strength and character that's right he's
got a lot of grace he's quite the
character he is free at last all right
aaron thank you so much